but the thing is dude but um you know
what it is that you're never you know um
I thought that you know I got on a
sitcom I thought it was gonna be a good
five year run yeah I didn't and you know
it died ugly yeah but like it did it did
for you what it needed to do probably I
mean you have to think like III watched
it I thought you were awesome and the
show was good I actually liked the show
it was it was good yeah but you know
when you when you watch your show you
know it's you know intrinsically and
obviously really funny when you watch
him on her family like you kill it but
like um probably the funniest guy on the
show but you can just tell that it's
just a fun show
to work on it's fun to watch you know
it's a it's a strong ensemble cast where
there's different people with different
styles of comedy and the way they
deliver line it's just a great show yeah
well but it started you know in the
bones it was that way from the beginning
and now we're gonna finish our eleventh
year which I can't believe that that's
crazy can you believe that but my point
went on your show is that I learned a
long time ago my manager one time was
represented she used to represent
Jessica Alba and she had a show that was
on like the CW where she played like an
action-adventure person this would have
been in the early Dark Angel yeah was
that the name of I think it was on and
then it was gone and I remembered oh
sorry Jessica's show got canceled he
goes no it did exactly for her what it
needed to do I mean for ABC it reminded
everybody that oh well I never had it
I've never worked for ABC before yeah
but you will again I know but now that I
got in did you create problems on the
set or anything no no I was great I
created relationships ed yeah was strong
and I like puffy I have to look at him
but it was you know star I met new
people and you know they all want to do
stuff with me again so yes because
you're you're but that doesn't yeah but
here's the thing though when you when
you tell people yeah my show got
canceled and there
people's immediate responses oh it
you'll get another thing right and then
you've been told that before but then
you have to wait for seven years you're
not gonna wait seven years and then
something happens you know fast if the
new you no no think okay hey it would be
called [ __ ] ish maybe see for sure
there went my career it would be Asian
ish yeah yeah yeah anyway you don't get
in trouble for that no is it good first
listen to me listen to me I glad you're
not gonna have to wait seven years and
here's why because modern family ends
next year and then somebody's gonna want
me to do something I'm gonna say yeah
with Bobby can be in it
[Music]